on passe à la politique c'est
aujourd'hui que George frche doit être
fixé sur son sort ses propos sur la trop
forte proportion de joueurs noir dans
l'équipe de France de football pourrait
lui valoir d'être exclu du parti la
Commission nationale du PS en charge du
dossier est réunie en ce moment même sa
décision est très attendue notamment par
les militants du Conseil représentatif
des associations noires par ailleurs je
vous rappelle que pour sa part c'est
Galen Royal a estimé que le président de
la Région langue de crousillon méritait
l'exclusion George frche dès hier se
disait victime d'un procès stalinien ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il tient
des propos provocateurs voire scandaleux
il a été condamné à une amende cette
semaine à Montpellier pour avoir traité
l'archie de sous-hommes léoland Berton
Pascal pense la commission des conflits
n'a pas encore rendu son avis mais pour
George frche les dés sont déjà jetés
ainsi dés hier il annonce qu'il s'attend
à être exclu du Parti socialiste du
temps de Staline les jugements étaient
fait à l'avance on faisait comparaître
les accusés et ensuite on lisait le
jugement et bien vous avez vu que le
jugement est fait il a été négocié
j'imagine entre Madame Royale et Madame
tobira avant le voyage aux
Antilles voilà c'est ce qu'on a appelé
en 1917 fusiller pour
l'exemple ce sont ses propos en novembre
dernier sur la composition de l'équipe
de France de football qui valent à
George fresche d'être traduit devant la
commission des conflits il aurait
déclaré dans cette équipe il a 9U BLS
sur 11 la normalité serait qu'il y en
ait trois ou quatre ce serait le refet
de la société mais là s'il y en a autant
c'est parce que les blancs sont nuls
j'ai honte pour ce pays
ou là le président de la Région
langdocous sillon et de l'agglomération
de Montpellier a beau expliquer qu'il
n'a pas tenu exactement ses propos et
qu'il n'est pas raciste le toé est
national d'autant qu'il en est pas à son
premier dérapage quelques mois
auparavant il a été suspendu du bureau
national du PS après avoir traité des
représentants archis de sous-hommees au
conseil régional certains alliés exigent
désormais sa démission N tous que après
avoir redérapé 6 mois après le dérapage
gravissime sur lesarchie ça veut dire
que Monsieur fresche a du mal à
contrôler ses propres sa propre
expression et donc ça recommencera dans
2 mois 3 mois 6 mois et on peut pas se
payer une crise comme ça tous les 3 mois
quelle que soit la décision de la
commission des conflits du Parti
socialiste George frche reste toujours
président de la Région longue
d'cousillon et de l'agglomération de
Montpellier hier le groupe socialiste au
conseil régional lui a d'ailleurs
renouvelé un soutien
massif